for the longest time this guy would come
on the show and he would go to great
trouble to to make this animated show
that he called pale force and used to
come on he said Conan I've made this
show and it stars you and he said and I
and you're in and his welcome and I was
always really you know like Oh at first
it mister optimistic that would be a
great thing and then this show would go
out of its way you went it was it really
captured our essence as Conan and I are
both very pale yeah that and yeah show
was you know instead of feeling this
incredible shame about our pic are
disgusting paleness yeah you know my
brother-in-law Paul nose came up with
this idea of where we're superheroes and
we actually fight crime with our pal me
yeah the only problem I had every time
was you depicted yourself in one way and
you depicted me in quite a different way
I think we have the opening actors new
captures are in this clip from pale
force
[Music]
Fuki bloody skin
[Music]
it's a guarantee
making wonderful this relate
you may I may even do I think you must
have made at least like 15 or 20 of them
there are a lot and you're coming back
in and everyone I behaved like a coward
I cry you saved the day I get hit by
Lake had done at dandelion and fall over
and wet your pants and I would wet my
pants constantly and I would and and it
would be over the crowd would love it
and then I would have you on again who
is the Charlie Brown Lucy on the
football over and over and over again it
was really fun nice to take that trip
down humiliation Lane
you